we have the graph of three functions
here and we're told that one of them is
the function f one is its first
derivative and then one of them is the
second derivative we just don't know
which one is which and so like always
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out
alright now the way I'm going to tackle
it is I'm gonna look at each of these
graphs and try to think what would their
derivatives look like so for this first
one we can see our derivative right over
here is our slope of our tangent line it
would be a little bit negative and then
it gets more and more and more negative
and as we approach this vertical
asymptote right over here it looks like
it's approaching negative infinity so
the derivative would actually over here
it would be a little bit less than zero
but then it would get more and more and
more negative and then it would approach
negative infinity so it would have a
similar shape general shape to the graph
itself at least to the left of this
vertical asymptote
now what about to the right of the
vertical asymptote right to the right of
the vertical asymptote it looks like the
slope of the tangent line is very
negative
it's very negative but then it becomes
less and less and less less and less and
less negative and it looks like it is
approaching it is approaching zero so on
this side the derivative starts out
super negative and then it looks like it
is the derivative is going to asymptote
towards zero something like that so
based on what we just it actually looks
like so based on what I just sketched it
just looks like this right graph is a
good candidate for the derivative of
this left graph you might say what's
wrong with this blue graph well this
blue graph out here notice it's positive
so if this were the derivative of the
left graph then that means that the left
graph would need a positive slope out
here but it doesn't have a positive
slope it's a very it's a slightly
negative slope becoming super negative
and so right here we're slightly
negative and then we become very
negative and so maybe this is let's call
let's call this F and maybe this is f
prime this is f prime right over here
and now let's look at this middle graph
what would its derivative do so over
here our slope is slightly negative and
then it becomes more and more and more
and more and more negative and so the
derivative of this might look like it
has to be it has to be slightly negative
but then it gets more and more and more
and more negative as we approach that
vertical asymptote and on the right side
of the vertical asymptote our derivative
is very positive here and then it gets
less and less and less and less and less
and less positive and so we start our
derivative would be very positive and
then it would get less and less and less
and less positive it looks like it might
the slope here might be asymptoting
towards zero so our graph might look
something like that well the left graph
right here looks a lot like what I just
sketched out as a candidate derivative
for this blue graph for this middle
graph and so I would say that this is F
then this is the derivative of that
which would make it f Prime and then we
already established that this right
graph is the derivative of the left one
so if it's the derivative of F prime
it's not f prime itself it's the second
derivative so I feel pretty good about
that and just for good measure we could
think about what the derivative of this
graph would look like here the slope is
slightly negative but then it gets more
and more and more and more and more
negative so the derivative would have a
similar shape here and then here our
derivative would be very positive and it
gets less and less and less and less and
less positive and so we start very
positive and then it gets less and less
and less and less and less positive and
so as a general shape it actually does
look a lot like this first graph but the
reason why I'm not going to say that
this first graph is the derivative of
the right hand graph is because this
right hand graph was the only good
candidate that we had for the derivative
of the left hand graph and so I feel
pretty good with what we selected that
this middle one is f the left one is the
first derivative and the right one is
the second derivative